وعلى كل حال سالنا الناس هل ندمت على
اختيارك لدراستك ومهنتك وما البديل الذي
تفضله لو عاد بك الزمان الى الوراء نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الدراسه قعدتي 17 سنه ندرس وفي الاخر ولا
يتعين بشهادتي ولا استفدت بيها باي حاجه
غير في حاجه واحده بس وانا رايح اتجوز انت
معاك ايه معاك كليه كذا انت هتعمليها على
كده
واشتغلت في دراستي ومهنتي الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
دراسه فيها ثاني يعني لو رجعت ثاني للزمن
هاكمل دراسه فيها ثاني وهشتغلها ثاني خالص
القسم بتاعي جدا وحابب الكليه بتاعتك جدا
وشايف ان شاء الله مع الوقت يعني لما تخرج
وكده معه التدريبات والحاجات ام الكورسات
اللي انا المفروض اخذها فانا المفروض ان
شاء الله هنلاقي وظيفه حلوه مستنيه
المباراه بتاعه لو هيرجع بها الزمن كده
انا اختار الدراسي
وبعد كده المهنه
لان الدراسه هي اللي بترفع البني ادم وهي
القيمه الاولانيه يعني في الحياه
انا حبيت المهنه دي والحمد لله ابدعت فيها
عملت حاجات جميله قوي الدراسه انا ما شفتش
نفسي في الدراسه عشان كده انا افضل يعني
انا بحب مهنتي وبفضل مهنتي تماما الحمد
لله على الوضع الحالي
ولو رجع بنا الزمن باذن الله برده هاختار
اللي انا فيه لان الحمد لله رب العالمين
همم انا ما كنتش متوقع لنفسي كده
والحمد لله يعني تميزت فيها
الواحد عنده اهل همم ان هم قدروا يوصلوا
لنا الحته دي بس بعد كده بقى انت خلاص
[موسيقى]
بدا يبص وياخذ خطوه عشان يدور